so you started this book years ago um
but i have to say it seemed very very
relevant to today
and i think the thing that is stunning
was stunning to me
was that abraham lincoln was essentially
a third party candidate
uh he he was kind of a nobody uh up to
that point he's like a former one-term
member of congress rattling around the
midwest
uh and then there is this uh new startup
party called the republican party that
just kind of comes out of nowhere
yeah and and he wins a four-way race
yeah
39.8 of the vote and just as someone you
know grows up in this country
venerating abraham lincoln like i was
like what
no i i you know and i i totally
understand why you uh would gravitate to
that part and i i actually originally
that section was two or three times as
long because i got into like the real
like electoral mechanics of how the whig
party was supplanted by the republican
party which you're right it's the most
successful third party in american
history um and there's a lot to learn
from it people think that you know
it's important to remember for folks
that you know our constitution doesn't
mention political parties it does
mention journalists i like to point out
but it doesn't mention political parties
that's because the founding fathers
which was my last book is about
washington's farewell
he was an independent as a matter of
principle uh the founding fathers
expected that members of congress would
represent their conscience and their
constituents but not through the filter
of party
eventually within their lifetime they
realized that was perhaps inevitable but
you know the democrat the federalist
party is supplanted by the wig party
which then falls apart because it fails
to take a stand on slavery that's
distinct and clear the defining issue of
the time uh then there's an
anti-immigrant know-nothing party that
emerges that lincoln refuses to join
although it's the first nativist party
that you know is very resonant today and
in the way the republican party is
created and how quickly it rises it's a
big tent moderate progressive party
dedicated to opposing slavery some
people oppose its expansion some people
want complete abolition
and it really ends up seating the states
of the fastest growing areas the upper
midwest and and the northeast
and lincoln
after losing a senate race but his
speeches uh against slavery were in
slavery's expansion were so powerful
that he developed a national reputation
is sort of this young fresh-faced
compromised candidate he's the moderate
from the midwest
and and he has a reputation for honesty
and he's not seen as a radical
as i say he's a reconciler in a time of
radicals and reactionaries and that
rockets him up to to lead the nation at
the start of the civil war without any
executive experience and no military
experience and one term in congress
and and he succeeds because of his
character and because of his capacity to
grow and it's a reminder that you know
the study of history
you know shows very clearly i think that
character is the single most important
quality of the president
bar none
most successful third party indeed uh so
the republican party starts out as a
northern anti-slave party which uh is
not the way most people think of it
today i mean
it's kind of reversed rules in terms of
dominance
um
thanks to
uh the civil rights act the the 1960s
so lincoln becomes president and that
almost immediately kicks off the civil
war in essence because there are
there there were candidates who were
vying for
uh
for votes in the south neither of whom
was abraham lincoln uh and then when
lincoln won with essentially
uh exclusively northern support then the
south uh decides to secede shortly
thereafter and lincoln finds himself a
wartime president with as you described
very limited experience in that realm
yeah and and you know it he wins
actually the the the states in the
pacific california oregon and i believe
washington at that point certainly
california and oregon but they have you
know they they have incredibly small
populations uh
and and but you're right it's it's the
energy in the country his was in the
upper midwest and the northeast and
that's what he wins and he lincoln
doesn't even appear on the ballot
in the deep south um and and what you
see also is that the the the planter
class the the slave owners who were
pushing secession
never dared initially bring it to a
popular vote in the states they tried to
do it in closed partisan uh conventions
and then they they relied on the
essentially the violence uh beginning
with the focus on on fort sumter
um that feeling they knew the feeling of
resentment and revenge would create its
own kind of remorseless logic and people
thought well we'll just have a quick war
and get this over with but of course
that's not what happened
and and lincoln who really is a man of
peace in a time of war
um is the least likely guy but he he
studies quickly he develops a theory of
of war and he relies on his
interpersonal absence of malice you know
the the defining characteristics i see
you know he's he's temperamentally a
moderate man but he combines moderation
with moral courage and i think that's
something that you and i share and focus
on is is that that's that that's the
magic combination that too often is
missing
too many people look at moderates and
see an absence of moral courage and too
people with moral courage assume a sense
of moral superiority and that's not the
way to persuade people democracy depends
on persuasion and even in the middle of
a civil war what's so extraordinary is
that lincoln still believes that there's
more than unites us than divides us he
refuses to demonize people he disagreed
with yes even when they're calling for
his death he believes that you empathize
with your opponents as a means of
reasoning with them
it's the politics of the golden rule and
i think it's so inspiring and it was
unusual in his time too don't get me
wrong
uh but but it is it's the reason he's on
a higher level than any president or any
american political figure
yeah this is a quote that i feel like
everyone should take to heart there are
so many lincoln quotes uh in this book
that i was reminded of uh but here's
here's one that spoke to me if you would
win a man to your cause first convince
him you are his sincere friend
but mark him as one to be shamed and
despised he will retreat within himself
close all avenues to his head and his
heart and i think that's totally true
it's totally
and it seems like like that that's a
fundamental lesson that everyone just is
completely ignored nowadays well it is
and and this is something that you get
grief for sometimes in a good good good
faith attempt to reach out and empathize
with people and hear where they're
coming from and in in the current
environment you know that basic quality
of empathy let's be honest has been
strained
it's difficult
in environments you know where people
are believing a self-evident big lie
bush piocon man who tried to overturn an
election
that's going to strain our capacity for
empathy when you see people doubling
down on that
but if lincoln could
continue with that spirit of empathy
even the middle of the civil war when he
he would not demonize people disagrees
with in public or private
you know that that's a that's a that's a
that's a tall order that's a that's a
big example but but it really isn't
coming upon us to try we may miss that
mark
but but it really is incumbent upon us
for try because that's how we get out of
this ultimately you know i mean every
knowledge of human nature would suggest
that and and and all the
the the emotional reflexes and politics
are
set up the other way
but we're going to need to find a way to
transcend that to reconcile again and
and so i know that you understand that
dynamic oh he literally had people
threatening his life and he would say uh
it's okay like we we'd be doing the same
thing in their shoes i thought that was
like just an incredible attitude
yeah
it's remarkable especially when you see
how he combines he combines opposites
and and he does you know he personally
swings between tragedy and comedy
and and depression and and this sort of
you know tendency to tell jokes all the
time which is really a form of
self-medication for him but which leads
other people his contemporaries to
accuse him of being insufficiently
serious
um you know there's that story early in
the book where after a brutal union
defeat
his friend isaac and arnold congressman
from illinois goes to visit him in the
white house and he's sitting on the
second floor in front of a fireplace and
he's reading from a book of his favorite
humorist artemis and ward and it wore
like another of his favorites patron v
nasby play characters i mean it's
actually a very
it's like it's it's satire it's first
person satire in the kind of way that
the original stephen colbert show did
uh where they're playing a character
anyway arnold
sees him laughing by the fireplace after
this brutal union defeat and he's
furious at his friend he says what the
hell are you doing how can you laugh at
a time like this
and then in arnold's
memoir he he describes lincoln as
throwing down the book and turning to
him with tears in his eyes and saying do
you not realize that if i could not find
some way to get relief that my heart
would break
and that's when he realized that the
laughter and the storytelling and the
joking was a form of self-medication
which i think is profound i mean he bore
an unbelievable burden uh and
one of the themes maybe the predominant
theme in the book uh is that he
thought you needed to lead a hard war
and then follow with a very soft peace
and
the
for a man who is not naturally
himself militaristic to be leading a
hard war uh just seemed like an
extraordinarily difficult burden to bear
one of the things that also blew my mind
was the war drags on and on for four
years and then the next election is up
uh 1864.
and people are saying to him it's like
hey you don't need to have this election
because you know guess what there's a
war on uh and he insists on having the
election
um
but but there is a period during which
he's not
favored to win
oh
he's convinced he's gonna lose in august
before the election he circulates a
letter that he has written himself
predicting his defeat
closes the envelope seals it has his
cabinet sign it
and he it's literally to to be witness
to his own silent prediction of his
defeat
and and of course things change you know
importantly sherman takes atlanta
uh which changes the tone of the war
um and and
during this time the democrats are
running against him and the democrats
are like hey everyone if you're tired of
this war bowed us in and then we'll have
peace with the south and all be well and
you have to like you have to hear that
and be like wow that'd be a pretty
compelling
pitch uh you know after years and years
of war so like that i like and if you
can imagine if he loses that race and
the democrats are like hey we're in like
peace with the south there is no united
states of america as we know today
everything changes you know
that's the thing i mean he believes that
you know
that
you have to win on the battlefield and
in uh in the election for his vision of
a magnanimous piece to work the book is
about how you win a piece right the book
is about lincoln's plan to win the peace
after winning the war in his vision for
national reconciliation and
reunification
um and and and what is so extraordinary
is he comes up with this without any
historic precedent because there's never
been a civil war on that scale before he
comes up with a basic formula that you
indicated unconditional surrender
followed by a magnanimous peace and
there were people in his time
saying look we've lost three quarters of
a million americans
you know that
lets us have peace let's have a
ceasefire he gets brought ceasefire
offers from the confederates on at least
two occasions and he refuses them
easy political win right yeah i know he
would say he would say the war is over
and we won like you feel like nine out
of 10 political leaders would take that
yeah and and they would be wrong because
what lincoln understood was that the
political will to end slavery would
evaporate yes if there was a ceasefire
before surrender which is why he'd
refuse he said i know one man desires
peace more than i but i am unwilling to
accept a peace on such terms that would
guarantee the next war if you don't
remove the root cause of the war it's
not peace
you know and and so a just war must be
followed by a just peace but you need to
end the fundamental underlying issue
which is slavery
and also the idea that states have a
right to secede and so that's why an
unconditional surrender needed to be
proceed needed to precede a magnanimous
peace but even in that there were people
in his own party who want vengeance yeah
and he's saying no that's not the way we
need to build our enemies back up
and and we need to you know have
political reform economic expansion move
the nation's attention westward um and
then and then cultural reintegration
which will take time moving toward a
multi-racial and majoritarian democracy
which is the thing had been
fundamentally resistant
um but but he is so farsighted and and
where the book you know we we may get
there in the conversation but where the
book ends up going is that his vision
ends up being vindicated in the wake of
the second world war where we pursue a
policy of unconditional surrender
followed by a magnanimous peace and it
works
well some of the signs of the fact that
he did want a magnanimous piece is when
he talks about
letting the confederate president
essentially leave the country be like
well you know
hopefully
someone can just make sure he gets out
because
uh he doesn't want to to execute him but
he also obviously he can't just have him
hanging around
and he tells his generals to let him up
easy let everyone go home let them keep
their horses just wanna have to give
them back their families
uh which would be a very tough stance to
to
uh hold on to after years and years of
of conflict and then people all telling
you that after you win like you know we
have to
um
to punish the the
treasonous
uh
rebels
so he
presides over the end of a war that he
had opportunities to end earlier but not
unconditionally and so he's like look
you need an unconditional surrender
eventually robert e lee does capitulate
and and uh surrenders
um and unfortunately
uh lincoln is assassinated very very
shortly thereafter
uh it it seems like
there is uh there's no real opportunity
even to celebrate the end of the war
before people are cast in the morning
yeah
that that's exactly right and and the
magnanimous piece that lincoln had been
evangelizing for um that seemed to be
carrying the day i mean you know he's
assassinated five days after lee
surrendered appomattox the generous
terms of which that grant writes are
basically terms that he had received
from lincoln in their
detailed meetings
but you know one of the things that
happened was is that feeling of
magnanimity
of of of we must reunite the nation is
immediately replaced by by a feeling of
revenge
so lincoln's martyrdom helps solidify
the union in some respect but it also
gets us back
ironically off
it it harms his legacy because we get
off a path of anonymity towards one of
vengeance
andrew johnson is the worst possible
person to take over for him and um and
and and where lincoln had wanted the
rank and file amnesty let them you know
have their guns to shoot crows with and
their horses to plow with he he as you
said he was going to make a martyr of of
jefferson davis and the confederate
leadership by hanging them which is the
traditional punishment for treason but
he also wasn't going to let the planter
class the people who should have known
better the members of congress the
courts the military who who joined the
confederacy he wasn't going to give them
amnesty right away he wasn't going to
let them get their power back because he
knew that that would end up
being a restoration
of of the slave class even in the
absence of of of slavery itself
due to the you know 13th amendment which
he passed before he died
um which is a reminder by the way that
even if rights are in front of the
constitution they don't mean anything if
they're not enforced
um you know but but it just gets us off
on precisely the wrong path and the
opposite of what lincoln wanted but you
know one of the things he did understand
you want magnanimity but you still need
accountability for leadership to proceed
reconciliation
[Music]
you